the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another song of ice and fire
video
in this video i will be showing you some
of the disturbing scenes from the books
that were left out of the game of
thrones television show
now there are so many different ones to
choose from but i just ended up writing
down some of the ones that really
affected me the first time i read them
as we all know there are some very dark
scenes in game of thrones but even the
show left out some scenes from the books
that could be seen as shocking or
unsettling
so let me show you some of the scenes
that stayed with me long after i read
them
now in the game of thrones television
show we got to see an amazing fight
between brienne and sandor clegane
during the fight in the show we did see
brienne get injured to some extent
but this is nothing in comparison to
what happens to her in the books
the character brienne ends up fighting
in the books goes by the name of biter
and we did see this character in the
show during jack nagar's introduction
he was one of the three men that was
locked up inside the cage
now much later in the books biter is
traveling with a band of outlaws
eventually brianne does run into him at
the end at the crossroads
and there just so happens to be several
small kids staying at the end
so naturally brianne wants to make sure
nothing happens to them
and one of the outlaws is actually
wearing sandor clegane's helmet
but brienne ends up killing him now we
all know she can handle herself against
almost anyone
but that doesn't happen when she fights
biter when these characters fight
this is what it says happens biter
crashed into her shrieking
he fell on her like an avalanche of wet
wool and milk white flesh
lifting her off her feet and slamming
her down into the ground she landed in a
puddle with a splash that sent water up
her nose and into her eyes
all the air was driven out of her and
her head snapped down against some
half-buried stone with a crack
no was all that she had time to say
before he fell on top of her
his weight driving her deeper into the
mud one of his hands were in her hair
pulling her head back the other groped
for her throat
oathkeeper was gone from her grasp she
had only her hands to fight him
but when she slammed a fist into his
face it was like punching a ball of wet
white dough
he hissed at her and she hit him again
again again
smashing the heel of her hand into his
eye but he did not seem to feel her
blows
she clawed at his wrist but his grip
just grew tighter
though blood ran from the gouges where
she scratched him he was crushing her
smothering her she pushed at his
shoulders to get him off her but he was
heavy as a horse
impossible to move when she tried to
knee him in the groin
all she did was drive her knee into his
belly biter ripped out a handful of her
hair
my dagger brienne clutched at the
thought desperate
she worked her hand down between them
finger squirming under his sour
suffocating flesh searching until they
finally found the hilt
biter locked both his hands about her
neck and began to slam her head against
the ground
the lightning flashed again this time
inside her skull
yet somehow her fingers tightened and
removed the dagger from the sheath
with him on top of her she could not
raise the blade to stab
so she drew it hard across his belly
something warm and wet gushed between
her fingers
bite her hissed again louder than before
and let go of her throat just long
enough to smash her in the face
she heard her bones crack and the pain
blinded her for an instant
when she tried to slash at him again he
grabbed the dagger from her fingers and
slammed a knee down onto her forearm
breaking it then he seized her head
again and resumed trying to rip it off
her shoulders
brienne could hear dog barking and men
shouting all about her
in between the claps of thunder she
heard the clash of steel on steel
sir heil she thought sir hail had joined
the fight but all that seemed far away
and unimportant
her world was no larger than the hands
at her throat in the face that loomed
above her
the rain ran off his hood as he leaned
in closer his breast stanked like cheese
gone rotten
brienne's chest was burning and the
storm was behind her eyes
blinding her bones ground against each
other inside of her
biter's mouth gaped open impossibly wide
she saw his teeth yellow and crooked
filed and sharpened into points
when they closed on the soft meat of her
cheek she hardly felt it
she could feel herself falling down into
the dark i cannot die yet she told
herself
there was something i still need to do
biter's mouth tore free
full of blood and flesh he spat grinned
and sank his sharpened teeth into her
flesh again this time
he chewed and swallowed he is eating me
she realized
but she had no strength left to fight
him off any longer she felt as if she
were floating above herself
watching the horror as if it were
happening to some other woman
to some stupid girl who thought she was
a knight it will be over soon she told
herself
then it will not matter if he eats me
biter threw back his head and opened his
mouth again
howling and stuck his tongue out at her
it was sharply pointed
dripping blood longer than any tongue
should be
sliding from his mouth out and out and
out red and wet and glistening
it made a hideous sight obscene his
tongue is a foot long brilliant thought
just before the darkness took her why it
almost looks like a sword
as you can see this was one of the most
vicious fight scenes we have ever seen
this was so much more disturbing than
the fight she had with sandor clegane in
the show
biter was actually eating her alive and
he would have easily finished her off
but someone does end up saving berean at
the very end of that scene
brienne was losing consciousness
therefore she wasn't exactly sure what
she was looking at
you see what happened was gendry
actually saved her by shoving a sword
through the back of his head
out the front of his mouth now
thankfully brienne did survive
but it will obviously take her a while
to recover from some of the injuries
the next scene from the books i want to
show you happens in king's landing
this time it involves cersei qyburn and
a character known as the blue bard
he never does show up in the game of
thrones television show but what happens
to him in the books is very gruesome to
say the least
one thing i found interesting was even
though we never got to really know this
character
blue bard this scene still had an effect
on me
once again cersei shows exactly how
heartless she can be
now for those of you that don't know
blue bard is a singer who is in service
of house tyrell
all the young ladies seem to like him in
the way he sings he's actually one of
the singers at tommen and marjorie's
wedding
as you all know cersei does not like
margaery at all
she wants to do any and everything she
can to get her out of king's landing
so cersei decides she wants to make it
look like margery has been sleeping
around with other characters
cersei wants the blue bard to admit and
testify against marjorie claiming that
he himself has slept with her but he's
not about to admit to something he has
never done
well that was a big mistake because
cersei isn't about to allow him to get
off that easily
so cersei has qyburn heard him in many
different ways
until he does agree to go along with
whatever she says about margaery
this is what happens in the scene even
in the black cells
all they got from him were denials
prayers and begs for mercy
before long blood was streaming down his
chin from all his broken teeth
and he wet his dark blue breeches three
times over
yet still the man continued to tell his
lies is it possible we have the wrong
singer cersei asked all things are
possible your grace
have no fear the man will confess before
the night is done
down here in the dungeons qyburn wore
rough spun wool and a blacksmith's
leather apron
to the blue bard he said i am sorry if
the guards were rough with you
their courtesies are sadly lacking his
voice was kind
all we want from you is the truth i've
told you the truth the singer sobbed
iron shackles held him hard against the
cold stone wall
we know better qyburn had a razor in his
hand
its ed's gleaming faintly in the
torchlight he cut away the blue bard's
clothing
until the man was naked but for his high
blue boots
the hair between his legs was brown
cersei was amused to see
tell us how you pleasured the little
queen she commanded
i never i i sang was all i sang and
played
her ladies will tell you they were
always with us her cousins
how many of them did you have carnal
knowledge of none of them i'm just a
singer
please qyburn said your grace may happen
the poor man only played for marjorie
while she entertained other lovers
no please she never i sang i only sang
lord qyburn ran a hand up the blue
board's chest
does she take your nipples in her mouth
during your love play
he took one of them between his thumb
and forefinger and twisted
some men enjoy that their nipples are as
sensitive as a woman's
the razor flashed the singer shrieked on
his chest
a wet red eye wet blood cersei felt ill
part of her wanted to close her eyes to
turn away to make it stop
but she was the queen and this was
treason lord tywin would have not turned
away
in the end the blue bar told them his
whole life
back to his first name day cersei blamed
marjorie tyrell for this
if not for her the blue bard might have
lived a long and fruitful life
singing his little songs and betting pig
girls and crofter's daughters
her scheming forced this on me she has
soiled me with her treachery
by dawn the singer's high blue boots
were full of blood
and he had told them how margaery would
fondle herself as she watched her
cousins pleasuring him with their mouths
who were they the queen demanded in the
wretched wat named sir tala the tall
lambert turnberry the red wine twins
ozny kettleblack hugh clifton and her
very own brother
the knight of the flowers that
displeased cersei
she dared not besmarch the name of the
hero of dragonstone
besides no one who knew sir loris would
ever believe it anyway
the red wines could not be a part of it
either without the arbor and its fleet
the realm could never hope to rid itself
of the euron crow's eye
and his accursed iron men all you're
doing is spitting up the names of men
you saw about her chambers
we want the truth the truth the blue bar
looked at her with one blue eye that
qyburn had left him
blood bubbled through the holes where
his front teeth had been
i might have misremembered horus and
harbor had no part in this did they
no he admitted not them as for soloris
i am certain marjorie took pains to hide
what she was doing from her brother
she did i remember now once i had to
hide under the bed when sir loris came
to see her
he must never know she said i prefer
this song to the other
leave the great lords out of it that was
for the best
the others though sir talent had been a
hedge knight
alibar zou was an exile and a beggar
clifton was the only one of the little
queen's guardsmen
now i know you feel better for having
told the truth you will want to remember
that when marjorie comes to trial
if you were to start lying again i won't
i'll tell it true
and after you will be allowed to take
the black
you have my word on that cersei turn to
qyburn
see that his wounds are cleaned and
dressed and give him milk of the poppy
for the pain
now even though i felt no connection or
interest in blue board
the scene still sickened me because
cersei did this to an innocent man
this is only one example of how evil she
can be just to get what she wants
this man will never be the same not only
was he sliced and diced beyond all
recognition
but now he set out to live the rest of
his life at the wall this really made me
hate cersei even more than i already did
now if i'm gonna talk about some dark
and disturbing scenes
then you know i have to talk about her
old friend theon greyjoy
the show did do a really good job at
showing what he went through while he
was in custody of ramsay bolton but the
books are able to go into so much more
detail
the next scene i want to show you is
when we first find out theon greyjoy is
now
going by the name of reek you see when
ramsay captures theon in the books
we don't see him again for a very long
time he essentially disappears from the
story
so you can only imagine what he's going
through during this
when we finally do see him again he has
definitely been transformed into reek
this is what it says when he finally
shows back up in the book
the rat squealed as he bit into it
squirming wildly in his hands
frantic to escape the belly was the
softest part
he tore at the sweet meat the warm blood
running over his lips
it was so good that it brought tears to
his eyes his own belly rumbled as he
swallowed
by the third bite the rat had ceased to
struggle and he was feeling
almost content then he heard the sound
of voices outside the dungeon door
at once he stilled fearing to even chew
his mouth was full of blood and flesh
and hair but he dared not spit or
swallow
he was listening in terror stiff a stone
to the scuff of boots and the clanking
of iron keys
no he thought no please gods not now
not now it had taken him so long to
catch the rat
if they catch me with it they will take
it away and then they'll tell and lord
ramsay will hurt me
he knew that he ought to hide the rat
but he was so hungry
it had been two days since he had eaten
and maybe three
down here in the dark it was so hard to
tell though his arms and legs were thin
as reeds
his belly was swollen and hollow an ache
so much that he found he could not sleep
whenever he closed his eyes he found
himself remembering lady hornwood
after their wedding lord ramsay had
locked her away in the tower and starved
her to death
in the end she had eaten her own fingers
he crouched down in the corner of his
cell
clutching his prize under his chin blood
ran from the corners of his mouth as he
nibbled at the rat with what remained of
his teeth
trying to bolt down as much of the warm
flesh as he could before the cell was
opened
the meat was stringy but so rich he
thought he might be sick
he chewed and swallowed picking small
bones from the holes in his gums where
teeth had been yanked out
it hurt to chew but he was so hungry he
could not stop
now like most of us fans i wanted to see
theon suffer for what he did
not only for betraying rob and taking
winterfell but also for burning the farm
boys
i wanted to see some justice but i never
wanted it to go this far
if anything theon should have died or
been burned alive like he did the small
boys but to see this be done to a man
for years upon years is unnecessary
after a while it just becomes sad
alright now i want to move on to the
next scene i want to show you this one
happens during the night of ramsay's
wedding
in the game of thrones television show
they had ramsay marry sons of stark
but that's not what happens in the books
ramsay does not marry or assault sansa
in the books
he actually does this to her childhood
friend jane
now you see in the books they want
everyone to believe that jane is
actually arya
so it looks as if ramsay has married
into the stark family
but theon of course would know this is
not the real arya
since everyone in the north is almost
dead there really isn't anyone who can
dispute this
so the boltons move forward with ramsay
marrying the fake arya so they can
officially claim winterfell for
themselves
so once ramsay marries this girl he
takes her upstairs to his bedchamber
just like he did with sansa in the show
now let me show you how this scene
unfolds in the books
the bed chamber had been well prepared
for the consummation
all the furnishings were new brought up
from the borough town and the baggage
drain the canopy bed had a feather
mattress and drapes of blood red velvet
the stone floor was covered with
wolfskins a fire was burning in the
hearth
a candle on the bedside table on the
sideboard was a flagon of wine
two cups and a half a wheel of veined
white cheese
there was a chair as well carved of
black oak with a red leather seat
lord ramsay was seated in it when they
entered there's my sweet maid
good lads you may leave us now not you
reek
you stay reek reek it rhymes with peak
he could feel his missing fingers
cramping two on his left hand
one on his right and on his hip his
dagger rested
sleeping in its leather sheath but heavy
oh so heavy
it's only my pinky gone on my right hand
theon reminded himself
i can still grip a knife my lord how may
i serve you
you gave the wench to me who better to
unwrap the gift
let's have a look at ned stark's
daughter she is no kin to lord eddard
theon almost said
ramsay knows he has to know what new
cruel game is this
the girl was standing by a bedpost
trembling like a doe
lady arya if you will turn your back i
must needs unleash your gown
no lord ramsay poured himself a cup of
wine
laces take too long cut it off her theon
drew the dagger
all i need to do is turn and stab him
the knife is in my hand
he knew the game by then another trap he
told himself
remembering keira with her keys he wants
me to try to kill him
when i fail he'll fly the skin from the
hand i used to hold the blade
he grabbed a handful of the bride's
skirt stand still my lady
the gown was loose below the waist so
that was where he slid the blade in
slicing slowly so as not to cut her the
steel whispered through wool and silk
with a faint soft sound
the girl was shaking theon had to grab
her arm to hold her still
jane jane it rhymes with pain he
tightened his grip
as much as his main left hand would
allow finally the gown fell away
a pale tangle around her feet her small
clothes too
ramsay commanded rick obeyed when it was
done
the bride stood naked her bridal finery
a heap of white and gray rags about her
feet
her breasts were small and pointed her
hips narrow and girlish
her legs as skinny as a birds a child
theon had forgotten how young she was
sansa's age
arya would be even younger now despite
the fire in the hearth
the bedchamber was chilly jane's skin
was covered by goose prickles
there was a moment when her hands rose
as if to cover her breasts
but theon mouthed the silent no and she
saw and stopped at once
what do you think of her reek asked lord
ramsay
she what answer does he want what was it
the girl had said before the godswood
they all said that i was pretty she was
not pretty now
he could see a spider web of faint thin
lines across her back where someone had
whipped her
she is beautiful so so beautiful
ramsay smiled his wet smile does she
make your handcock hard reek
is it straining against your laces would
you like to sleep with her first
he laughed the prince of winterfell
should have that right
as all lords did in the days of old the
first night
but you're no lord are you only reek not
even a man
truth be told he then took another gulp
of wine
then threw the cup across the room to
shatter off a wall
red rivers ran down across the stone
lady arya
get on the bed yes against the pillows
that's a good wife now spread your legs
let us see what you have down there
the girl obeyed wordless theon took a
step back to the door
lord ramsay sat beside his bride slid
his hand along her inner thigh
then jammed two fingers up inside her
the girl let out a gasp of pain
you're dry as an old bone ramsay pulled
his hand free then slapped her across
the face
i was told that you'd know how to please
a man was that a lie
no my lord i was trained ramsay rose
the fire light shining on his face reek
get over here
get her ready for me for a moment he did
not understand
i do you mean my lord i have no
i with your mouth lord ramsay said and
be quick about it
if she's not wet by the time i'm done
disrobing i will cut off that tongue of
yours and nail it to the wall
somewhere in the godswood a raven
screamed the dagger was still in his
hand
he sheathed it reek my name is reek it
rhymes with weak
then reek bent to his task
i don't think i need to go into any more
details than this
obviously this was a very sick and
disgusting scene
however if their wedding night wasn't
bad enough
things would only get worse from here on
out ramsay would keep her locked up in
the tower
where she would be heard crying every
night she had been through so much
she did not believe theon when he
eventually told her he wanted to help
her escape
when theon does explain to her how they
can escape we find out even more
disturbing details about what ramsay has
done to her
this is what it said jane lifted her
wolf skins up to her chin
no this is some trick it's him it's my
my lord my sweet lord he sent you this
is just some test to make sure that i
love him
i do i do i love him more than anything
a single tear ran down her cheek
tell him you tell him i'll do what he
wants whatever he wants
with him or or what the dog or he
doesn't need to cut off my feet
i won't try to run away not ever i'll
give him sons i swear it
i swear it so as you can see not only
has ramsay forced her to do things with
him or wreak
but this also insinuates he's had her do
things with the dogs as well
it's just another example of how screwed
up ramsay really is
he is easily one of the worst characters
in all of a song of ice and fire
jane was only a sweet summer child with
a head full of stories and songs
who unfortunately lost her father her
only friend
her virtue her innocence and her sanity
as well
at the very least i would like to see
ramsay suffer the same fate in the books
as he did in the show
but if it were up to me i would have him
suffer even more
now it was very satisfying to see
ramsay's own dogs eat him alive
but it still ended too fast since he has
made so many characters suffer
he deserves that much and then some
anyways these are only a handful of
scenes from the books that are very dark
but believe me there are so many more
let me know what scenes really had an
effect on you
especially if there are ones i haven't
mentioned here i would love to hear them
i want to thank everyone for stopping by
to watch the video it really means a lot
to me
and i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you